es ist so ein kaltes feuchtes frühjahr
dass es unglaublich und deswegen sind
überall schnecken unterwegs aber es gibt
eine sache die richtig gut gegen
schnecken hilft kannst du mir mal den
joghurt geben dazu muss mir erst mal
helfen die nacht zu essen wir brauchen
nämlich eigentlich gar nicht den jungen
in den becher drin ist sondern wir
brauchen und den becher selbst also wenn
ihr solche großen joghurtbecher übrig
habt dann hebt die auf jeden fall auf
weil man schnecken so richtig gut von
den gemüse pflanzen fernhalten kann
das ist meine erfahrung nach wirklich
die effektivste methode wenn man eine
physikalische barriere schafft die die
gemüsepflanzen schützt so lange sie noch
klein sind von schneckenkorn bin ich gar
kein freund vor allem deswegen weil es
so viel effizientere und wirksamere
methoden gibt die gleichzeitig auch noch
schon sind für die schnecken und für die
ganzen anderen tiere die in unseren
gärten leben seht ihr dass ihr hat der
joghurtbecher diesen rand und stellt
euch mal vor ihr seid eine schnecke und
versucht hier dran hoch zu kriegen dann
ist spätestens hier an den rand schluss
außer ihr seid voll die durchtrainierte
power wegschnecke aber die allermeisten
schnecken können diesen rand hier nicht
überwinden und das können wir uns
zunutze machen
das ist das gleiche prinzip nachdem auch
schnecken ringe oder schnecken kragen
funktionieren
sie steckt man dann so ein bisschen in
die erde reihen so fünf zentimeter weil
die schnecken auch unterwegs sonst zu
den jungs fans ihren reihen griechen
könnten und damit sind die schnecken zu
100 prozent geschützt man muss dabei ein
bisschen darauf achten dass zum beispiel
keine andere pflanze jetzt so an den
schnecken kragen dran wächst wenn diese
pflanze hier jetzt zum beispiel so an
den schnecken kragen daran wachsen würde
dann könnten die schnecken das als
brücke benutzen und unsere jungen
pflänzchen trotzdem aufweisen aber
solange man das beachtet haben die
schnecken keine chance an die jungen
pflänzchen zu kommen und es gibt einige
jungen pflänzchen sie sehr sehr
empfindlich sind was schnecken fraß
angeht und die die schnecken super
lecker finden da sind zum beispiel die
salate und auch alle kohlgemüse wie zum
beispiel kohlrabi weißkohl rotkohl und
so weiter die sind so lecker für
schnecken dass die in einer nacht alle
jungs lenzen abbrechen können
ich habe da hinten zwei schnecken kragen
zu wenig gehabt und innerhalb von einer
nacht wand genau diese beiden pflänzchen
abgefressen ihr seid auch alle gurken
kürbis zucchini und melonen pflänzchen
immer mit einem schnecken kragen
schützen bis die groß genug sind um
einen nächtlichen schnecken besuch zu
überstehen
sie schnappen wir uns jetzt einen cutter
und schneiden hier den boden raus damit
wir das ganze dann über die jungen
pflänzchen darüber stülpen können soll
sie das dann aus und was auch ganz
wichtig ist diese henkel hier die müssen
auch ab weil die schnecken natürlich
sonst einfach hier so drauf rum kriechen
können und dann nicht diesen randhir
überwinden müssen
die müssen wir also auch irgendwie ihr
seht aber der unterschied ist schon ganz
schön groß sodass hier lässt sich wenn
man eine durchtrainierte riesen
spanische wegschnecke ist schon leichter
überwinden als dass ihr da haben die
keine chance die hier helfen richtig gut
gegen kleine schnecken aber wenn ihr
richtig dicke brummer in ihren gärten
habt dann kauft euch lieber die
richtigen schnecken kragen weil dann
helfen die nicht mehr so wirklich weiter
wenn ihr die kauft dann achtet darauf
dass die eine gute qualität haben es
gibt welche die gehen super schnell
kaputt die hier sind richtig schön fest
und ich packe euch gerne einen link in
die video beschreibung über die ihr die
guten stabilen schnecken kragen kaufen
könnt die hier die habe ich jetzt schon
fünf sechs jahre und es ist kein schaden
dran man kann die richtig
zusammendrücken diesen richtig schön
stabil
das erste produkt in fabians shoppen den
kennt er aus dem letzten oder vorletzten
video weil sie das noch nicht geschaut
habt verlinkt ich euch das gerne in der
video beschreibung der hat gerade seinen
garten shop aufgebaut und ich durfte mit
entscheiden welche sachen mit in den
shop kommen und der shop ist jetzt
geöffnet wenn ihr auch so transparente
becher übrig habt dann auch immer die
dinge ab machen hier
und wenn ihr den transparenten deckel
haben dann könnt ihr die auch als mini
treibhaus verwenden nicht ab jetzt hier
auch einfach den boden raus geschnitten
dann mache ich aber den deckel jetzt
drauf mit ihr habe ich frisch
gepflanzten kohl und da stimme ich dir
jetzt einfach drüber
das fungiert auch als schnecken schutz
aber ich habe eben auch den deckel drauf
sodass es darin auch noch ein bisschen
wärmer wird tagsüber dann aber gerne mal
lüften oder den deckel abnehmen bevor es
den pflänzchen darin zu heiß wird aber
gerade in kühlen nächten oder wenn es
jetzt so lange braucht bis der sommer
richtig in fahrt kommt dann hilft es den
pflanzen dass sie noch einen kleinen
wachstumsvorsprung bekommen ich habe
noch zwei andere schnecken tipps für
euch auf lager
damit ihr eure plage in den griff
bekommt was bei uns richtig gut hilft
auch wenn es ein bisschen nervig ist
wenn man abends mit der taschenlampe
nochmal loszieht und im großen eimer und
so viele schnecken einsammelt wie man
irgendwie findet im garten und die ganz
weit weg bringt wirklich weit weg bringt
und nicht zum nachbarn sondern wir
bringen die einfach über die
straßenseite und nahen fluss so dass sie
da weiterleben können wir sind es
unseren schnecken und dann auch ganz
wichtig wenn ihr schnecken probleme habt
ich bin ja eigentlich ein freund von
wilden garten und natürlichen werten
aber wenn ihr das gras um eure beete
drumrum schön kurz halte das ist jetzt
schon relativ lange her
dann kommen auch nicht so viele
schnecken in eure beete wie wenn das
richtig hoch steht das muss man einfach
sagen und dritten tipp habe ich auch
noch für euch wenn ihr hühner habt dann
zeigt sie so ein dass die immer neben
den beeten entlang laufen können
natürlich dürfen die nicht in die beete
wir uns im winter mal dass es auch toll
wenn dieser schnecken gelege dann
wegfressen können aber das hilft bei uns
richtig gut dass die einfach immer um
die beete drumrum rotieren mit unseren
elektronischen so dass die alle
schnecken einsammeln die für irgendwie
auf den weg in unsere beete sind ja
schnecken können einem das gärtner leben
schon echt vermiesen aber fast genauso
nervig sind blattläuse oder also wenn
ihr mit blattläusen zu kämpfen habt dann
schaut gerne mal da drüben vorbei
darüber habe ich nämlich auch schon mal
ein video gemacht da könnt ihr euch
anschauen was wirklich gegen blattläuse
hilft ansonsten geht raus macht die welt
ein bisschen grüner passt gut auf eure
gemüse pflänzchen auf und was sind
fleißig schnecken kragen und wir sehen
uns am samstag wieder für einer ist
video